ir
séitper laoconde symbole patrimoine
franais au musée du Louvre à Paris elles
avaient caché de la soupe au potiron
dans un thermos à
café objectif de leur action promouvoir
le droit à une alimentation saine et
durable on peut comprendre mais est-ce
que c'est le moment là-ce qui se passe
avec les agriculteurs ou autant plus que
l'écologie est un petit peu pointée du
doigt par les agriculteurs c'est
peut-être pas le moment après voilà
après G je sais que tu penses que c'est
c'est une bonne initiative on va en
parler et d'ailleurs il a du courage à
devenir loï membre de ripost alimentaire
pu qu'il sera avec nous dans un instant
vont-ils trop loin c'est la question
qu'on se pose ce soir où est-ce qu'ils
ont raison Gill pense qu'ils ont raison
on regarde la vidéo on en parle juste
après cl qui est membre du mouvement et
qui qui a du courage de venir ce soir il
sait queon il sait qu'il y a Gill qui va
le défendre qui va défendre le également
ce soir à part Gill personne bon ben
merci g merci d'être là g
regardez
qu'est-ce qu' est important qu'est-ce
qu'il y a de plus important l' le
droitimentation saine et durable notre
système agricole est
malade un français sur ne fait pas
touses repas tous les jours BONSOIR L
merci d'être là parce que c'est vrai que
c'est courageux de votre part de venir
membre de Rost aliment euh
louck pourquoi pour pourquoi vous avez
fait ça parce que je vois vous parlez
des agriculteurs euh qu'est-ce que vous
diriez vous aux agriculteurs parce que
c'est vrai que les agriculteurs ils ont
des normes qui font qu'aujourd'hui ils
ont ils ont beaucoup de mal est-ce que
vous vous comprenez la colère des
agriculteur ou pas ben vous savez nous
quand on fait ça c'est en tant que
citoyens qui font nos courses tout
simplement c'est ça ouais donc certes
quand on fait les courses on a sûrement
tous ressenti déjà l'impact mais il y a
l'autre versant il y a le versant le
quotidien des agriculteurs et ça bien
bien sûr bien sûr c'est juste dingue ce
qui se passe en fait on va chaque année
on a des trucs ahurissants qui se
passent et ça fait que s'empirer et là
c'est vrai que les agriculteurs il y a
un ralbol moi que je comprends
totalement qu'on comprend entièrement et
nous on s'inscrit comme solidaire de de
leur démarche bien sûr et je prendrai le
temps d'expliquer pourquoi on fait ça
j'ai un problème à chaque fois que je
vois les actions chaque fois que je vois
les actions je me dis ah c'est c'est dur
et ce qu'ils font et quand vous venez
sur le plateau à chaque fois je me dis
ils sont complètement je tris que ce
sont des gens sensés sont des gens qui
en plusà je vous trouve sympathique à
Cha fois je trouve vous expliquez bien
et cetera euh ça quand même non mais non
mais c'est
vrai- que
de ben il faut comprendre que moi j'ai
presque envie de dire autre chose c'est
pas que forcément on soutient c'est que
des émissions comme celle-ci soutiennent
ça on est déjà passé sur sur ton plateau
cyil plusieurs fois vous le savez enfin
si on vient c'est parce qu'on a fait ça
malheureusement donc en fait on fait
uniquement ça parce qu'on est contraint
aujourd'hui pour faire entendre un
message de jouer le jeu des mé làdus tu
as raison il a raison ï vrai làessus
parce que pas
fait il a raison sur un truc loïque
c'est que demain il nous appelle moi moi
je vraiment je suis Fran lo nous appelle
demain il va nous dire je veux parler
d'un truc voilà pour l'écologie pour
améliorer la planète pour améliorer je
suis sûr que je suis sûr qu'on va pas le
rappeler je suis d'accord avec lui je
suis sûr qu'on va pas le prendre alors
que là comme il a fait un happing c'est
vrai qu'on il est là ce
soiriss question c'est que du coup on
parle on parle de l'ppening et on parle
pas du fond c'est ça le sujet surtout
qui mais c'est le seul moyen il
AR c'est là que c'est un peu fairplay
c'est parce que vous nous invitez c'est
l'occasion d'en parler donc justement
moi j'aimerais vous expliquer qu'est-ce
qu'on entend par une sécurité sociale de
l'alimentation durable et pourquoi on
pense que c'est vraiment un pan
complémentaire de la lutte actuelle des
agriculteurs et pourquoi ça va
contribuer à améliorer leur vie par par
la suite et tout simplement le pouvoir
d'achat des Français on parle en fait
d'un plan qui permet à chaque français
d'avoir 150 € par mois à dépenser sur
une sélection de produits conventionnés
donc là on pourrait parler longtemps je
sais pas si on aura le temps de rentrer
dans détail mais vous vous maîtrisez
déjà le sujet sur le plateau on a un
problème où on a des agriculteurs qui
pendant des années ont fait des efforts
de dingue ou pour mettre en place des
normes hyper exigeantes en France sauf
qu'en face on laissé les la grande
distribution et cetera importer des
produits deétranger qui sont super chip
parce que la grande
distribution
question par
on pournervé comm ça je suis énervé
parce que c'est totalement hypocrite
vous faites cette action parce que vous
savez pas comment vous positionnez
pendant des années vous n'avez cessé
d'aider à criminaliser les agriculteurs
et aujourd'ui le mouvement écologiste en
France est un mouvement qui est
totalement à côté de la plaque en vous
avez contribué à criminaliser les
agriculteurs ils se sentent aujourd'hui
coupabl coupable de faire de
l'agriculture parce que attendez on est
je disais déjà on n pas le mouvement
écologiste on est des citoyens des gens
comme vous qui faisont leurs cours c'est
tout là on est en train de proposer aux
agriculteurs d'avoir que chaque Français
a un budget pour aller acheter leurs
produits plutôt que d'acheter les
produits ucrainiens en quoi est-ce que
c'est
att je peux permre defendre est
pasonsable ceux qui qui sont à la tête
des Mouv écol j'ai j'ai pas vécu toute
l'histoire fait pas d'amalg sur
question ils sont mal représentés par
les gens qui dirigent les mouvements
écolo aussi qui sont quand même
Desil questionnez un comportement de
délinquant et moi il y a un truc que je
trouve profondément injuste si c'était
des jeunes de lie qui dégrad des
monuments et ca c'est c'est c'est amende
t direct garde à vue là c'est des bobos
écolos tranquilles qui viennent avec
leurs St smth jeter de la soupe au
petiron sur les trucs déjà personne
n'intervient je comprends pas pourquoi
on leur dit rien et je sais même pas ce
qu' ce qu'ils ont c'est très grave de
faire ça pour moi ça mérite au moins une
grosse Amand voir un petit tour en
prison on ne peut pas dégrader comme ça
un nettoyer le musée pendant un mois
mais exactement on peut pas dégrader un
symbole comme ça national et
international d'une valeur inestimable
al qui cert est protégé évidemment mais
je pense que même s'il n'était pas
protégé il le ferait quand même c'est
honteux on peut pas euh sous prétexte de
vouloir faire passer un message
valoriser et encourager des
comportements de délinquant c'est
dégueulasse que vous faites al G qui est
d'accord avec moi je suis entièrement
d'accord il réveille nos consciences ils
sont très intelligents c'est réfléchis
ils savent très bien que la jocond est
protégé ils sont pas débiles non plus et
effectivement on on se plaint du manque
de soutien des agriculteurs eux les
soutiennent par un mouvement qui comme
ça nous interpelle moi je crée au
géniees ces gens-là vous ne les
comprenez pas parce qu'ils sont trop en
avant sur
voustal audible effectivement parce que
pendant des années on a opposé les
écolos aux agriculurs le représentant d'
écologie les ver
monsurés vous
voulezbem les gens c'est que les gens en
fait ils aient envie de les écouter
grâce à cette action mais c'est un effet
complètement cont laiss-moi finir c'est
un effet complètement contreproductif
puisque là en fait presque la totalité
de l'opinion publique trouve cette
action ridicule donc en fait les gens
ont qu'une envie même même si peut-être
au fond il dir ah c'est vrai que les
agriculteurs faut les aider ils voient
ce que vous faites ils se disent mais en
fait non en fait c'est
contreproductif je comprends franchement
je comprends que ce soit choquant mais
il y a quelques années j'aurais été à
votre place j'aurais été pareil j'aurais
j'aurais pointé du Doig je dis mais l
qu'est-ce que tu fous là qu'est-ce que
vous fa tous ensemble je comprends
parfaitement mais enfin vous étiez
peut-être pas ça fait 2 ans qu'on fait
ça dans dans le cadre d'autre campagne
et à nouveau on est obligé d'en venir à
là pour venir là parler de ces sujets on
parle pas n'importe quel sujet on parle
d'une solution de dingue non mais c'est
une nouvelle super positif on devrait
tous se jouer sur le plateau que depuis
plus d'un an 2 ans 3 ans on a des
collectifs comme le collectif pour la
sécurité sociale de l'alimentation qui
commencent à mettre ce sujet sur la
table ça veut dire que demain là moi
vous êtes en train de m'engueuler vous
êtes en train d'engueuler les gens qui
font ça un peu quand même he alors que
c'est des gens qui en sont en train de
dire ils sont ils ont fait des gardes à
vues elles sont revenu épuiser bon ok
elles sont pas traitées de manière égale
non non mais c'est vrai elles sont pas
traité de manière égale ce que vous
dites c'est complètement juste sur en
fonction de notre origine sociale et
cetera on serait pas traité de la même
manière j'ai envie un peu dire bah on
peut se le permettre bah c'est peut-être
le minimum qu'on peut faire pour essayer
de faire avancer ses causes aujourd'hui
on essaie de faire avancer un sujet qui
met 150 € par mois dans la poche des
gens ça sera pas du jour au lendemain
c'est une grosse dépense à faire mais il
y a des initiatives locales dont on peut
parler c'est très prometteur et à
nouveau on parle d'encourager les
agriculteurs français qui en peuvent
plus là qui sont en train d'avoir des
modes
d' par par par
qu' à nouveau on pas donc non mais c'est
le Mouv écologiste dans son
ensembleell joue c'est pas vous dis
désolé je vous ai interrompu du coup
mais je vous écoute je vous disais par
exemple les producteurs de cerises ça
n'existe plus en France parce qu'on leur
a mis tellement de taxes parce que les
ocolos ont tellement imposé qu'il a des
taxes qu'aujourd'hui en fait on est
obligé d'importer les cerises et il y a
plus de cerises
français ça est-ce que
vous l'idée en fait qu'est-ce que c'est
on a 150 € dans sa poche un chèque on va
dans un supermarché et on nous dit
regardez c'est 150 € donc c'est gratuit
c'est gratuit vous pouvez les dépenser
sur l'équivalent aujourd'hui de filières
qui ont pas encore disparu j'espère
qu'on va pas agir trop tard avec off va
pas agir trop t sur cette question de la
sécurité sociale de l'alimentation on va
leur dire achetez la pomme du sud de la
France achetez machin et cetera donc 150
€ c'est c'est absolument hallucinant ce
qui va se passer en comme impact non
mais par français vous vous rendez
compte et une dernière chose juste parce
que c'est absolument fondamental on
parle d'un coup d'éponge sur un tableau
en face aujourd'hui il y a 32 % de
Français qui arrivent pas à manger à
leur faim au quotidien c'est 22 millions
de personnes vous vous rendez compte là
l'idée certes c'est clivant certes c'est
chelou mais à nouveau on joue le jeu des
médias parce que vous nous l'imposez
mais là c'est censé aider ces personnes
là on a un agriculteur qui se suicide
par jour en France il y a des sujets
graves arrêtons nous nous nous mettre
sur la figure pourp sérieux et parlons
des vrais sujets qui compent et de
solution comme C il vont pas trop loin
non ils vont pas trop loin parce qu'il
pourrait aller plus loin moi mon
problème c'est que là l'argument il est
très bon en plateau mais je sais pas si
ces deux nanas elles ont le même
argument que vous déjà bien sûr que si
vous garantir elles ont le mêmeument de
se dire c'est comme ça qu'on va être
invité sur les plateaux parce que
justement moi je le reproche alors du
coup moi ça me PLA pas c'est triste
aussi VI moi je devrais pouvoir appeler
c comme il au début devrais pouvoir
l'appeler on est sur plateau ça marche
moi ça PLA
par VO gus ça vous déilise tu trou ça
nul a raison sur un truc je dis a raison
sur un truc et je le dis n'importe
quelle émission les gars arrêtez il faut
pas être hypocrite moment ils font pas
ça parce que tout m dire non mais ton
sujet il est chiant on va faire chier je
dis la vérité c'est vrai voilà donc ça
aussi à ce momentl j'aimerais un
communiqué directement où elles disent
on fait ça pour passer sur les plateau
le fait mais il le diffuse pas je veux
dire c'est pas diffusé pas forcément que
ce Médi il y médiia Gal on on est obligé
d'en venir là donc à nouveau ce qui est
génial il y a un point positif ce soir
de dingue vous nous invitez merci
beaucoup vraiment c'est je veux dire si
vous vous êtes français vous avez senti
la différence depuis 2 ans dans votre
panier de course vous trouvez ce qui se
passe pour les agriculteurs c'est c'est
juste qu'en à et qu'il faut les aider et
que Ben vous avez forcément il y a plein
de modes d'action mais typiquement vous
vous demandez la question comment j'aide
un collectif qui est en train d'agir
pour eux B venez à une réunion publique
on fait des portes ouvertes où il y a 2
heures pour parler tout ça en profondeur
on sait bien qu'ici on a'ura pas le
temps de vous expliquer tout le pourquoi
du comment mais venez passer la porte
alleer sur repostalimentaire.fr et aller
voir il y en a à Paris il y en a partout
en France et surtout on fait ça pour
soutenir et mettre en valeur des
initiatives qui ont déjà eu lieu à
Montpellier Nantes Paris de société de
pardon de excusez-moi sécurité sociale
alimentaire où les gens spontanément
sans que le gouvernement le fasse disent
ok vous savez quoi nous les 5 on vit
dans le même quartier on n pas tous le
même pouvoir d'achat on va tous mettre
50 € dans une dans une dans une caisse
pour que chacun puisse avir accès à
manger donc les gens le font deux même
et l'idée c'est d'aujourd'hui convertir
ces initiatives locales en une
initiative qui est soutenue par le
gouvernement moi ce que j'aime pas
làdedans c'est que c'est joli là c'est
libre alors tu as raison si tu avais pas
fait ça on t'aurait personne t'aurait
invité mais là c'est libre c'est joli
moi j'ai ce que j'ai peur c'est qu'après
on va se retrouver dans un monde où tout
sera souslexi glace tout sera fermé pour
pas qu'on fasse des des gestes comme ça
les gens ils seront fouillés à l'entrée
faudra laisser les trucs faud tout laiss
un peu plus de fouille et il y a un peu
plus de plexigl si en face les AGR on
quoi vivre c'est pas plus
mal truc les 150 € vous les trouvez où
alors c'est non non mais complètement
l'idée c'est ça représente une grosse
dépense et je le dis hein on est
transparent ça représente 12 milliards
d'euros par an en plus je te l'explique
120 milliards d'euros par an en plus
pour le budget aujourd'hui la sécurité
sociale parce qu'on parle de la sécurité
sociale on parle juste d'étendre ce
système dont on est super fier en France
depuis des décennies la sécurité sociale
des gens dans le monde entier bavent en
regardant ça et en se disant [__] mais
si seulement il y avait ça dans mon pays
là on veut juste l'étendre à
l'alimentation qui a un droit absolument
fondamental et
qui faut faut augmenter les impôts des
Français il y a plusieurs moyens d'abord
on passe donc on parle de passer de 500
à 620 ensuite ce qui se passe c'est les
in ouais mais non regarde non parce
qu'on se met tous les deux entre voisins
on se met tous les deux entre voisins
regarde le début de la solution elle est
là ils le font eux-mêmes 100 % de leur
poche il y a des initiatives qui
marchent là qui sont en train de nourrir
des gens qui sont en grande précariité
en France on commence par le faire
individuellement et ensuite l'état
progressivement rentre pas à 100 % il va
commencer par mettre 10 % % projetc non
et là on va chercher ensuite c'est comme
c'est super beau c'est génial aurais pu
avoir le même discours il y a 50 ans
quand on avait proposé la sécurité
sociale juge générale tu aurais sûrement
dit la même chose mais si après c'est
toujours plus facile de dire après c'est
toujours plus facile de le dire là tu
verras si demain on vit dans un monde
avec la sécurité sociale alimentaire et
que des gens peuvent enfin manger à leur
fin on sera tous d'accord ici tout le
monde mettra oui avec paye plus d'impôt
il mangera pas à
sa si un Français paye plus d'impôt il
mangera de moins en moins déjà ceux qui
sont en grande précarité c'est ceux qui
vont être le plus concernés et on peut
le faire intelligemment on peut aller
chercher l'argent où y en a trop 90% des
gens trouvent que vous allez trop loin
oUI NON à à 9% merci en tout cas d'avoir
été là loï voilà on en tout cas voyz moi
je suis pas d'accord avec moin on en
discute voilà on en discute et il a un
discours voilà qui qui qui est calme et
qui est posé et il dit les choses après
moi je dis aussi la
vérité c'est vrai que sans happing ils
sont invités sur aucun plateau
invitenous plus souvent sans qu'on a à
faire ça les agriculteurs quand il r
quand il retournent les panneaux
personne les invit exaement je suis
d'accord avec toi justement les
agriculteurs bravo Géraldine c'est le la
transition tu es vraiment formidable tu
m'ofes des colliers tu fais la
coanimatrice et en plus tu ne me
demandes pas d'augmentation tu es la
chronique